so around a year ago we started working
on hazel's animation system this was
something that existed to some extent
already pretty early on in the engine it
was a very simple and primitive system
back then some of you will remember that
i made a devlog about it a while ago
what you're watching at the moment is a
scene that tim made using
hazel's brand new animation system which
was primarily developed by xerox you may
remember him from such videos as
testing hazel's performance yeah he's
been around for quite a while now what i
thought i would show you guys today is a
little bit of what the development
process of this animation system was
actually like
it all started with this message from
xerox for animation going forward will
you be rolling your own or plan to
integrate something like oz
which is an open source c plus skeletal
animation library and toolset as you can
see to which i replied well i was
planning to roll my own but this looks
interesting i'll check it out now
me being me when i say thanks i'll check
it out i probably mean something more
along the lines of i will someday in my
life probably take a look at this thing
so about a month later
this xerox had just gone ahead and
slapped it in there were some issues
like for example the dependency on the
fbx sdk was something i was not too
thrilled about but a few days later it
was basically working although i was
told to not get too excited always a
good idea to profile your work and see
how it performs and in this case
well it ended up being pretty good now
because we're building a game engine
here it's very very important to
consider the workflow how is this
actually going to work and integrate
with the existing asset system how are
we going to be able to author animations
and just in general deal with them in
the editor in an actual production
quality way i think that's something
that a lot of people overlook
that kind of whole workflow system and
architecture
in a lot of ways is actually much more
challenging to design and implement
compared to the actual like physical
animation code as usual there ended up
being a bunch of issues that xerox and i
had to work through and who could forget
the physics system another super
important thing when you're working on a
game engine there are various systems
they have to work together not
everything is just an isolated test that
makes things more difficult and time
consuming and hey i mean it can be a
struggle sometimes lots of debugging
later and some excitement it was finally
starting to come together workflow and
all good things always take time we also
discovered that asim the library we were
using for like 3d model loading had its
problems
as i said it's a long process it was
around this time that we decided to kind
of officially switch to gltf as the most
supported hazel 3d model format now all
of this work had got us to a pretty good
position we were able to import
animations apply them to various meshes
we could switch between various
animation states as you're seeing in
this scene right here of course it would
be nice to blend between animation
states but hey has to start somewhere so
overall pretty good progress and then a
few months later out of nowhere xerox
had decided to rewrite the animation
system this time without using oz
animation but instead replacing it with
our own custom system we even briefly
considered using this new animation
system in lotum there 50 but ultimately
decided against it looks like xerox had
fulfilled the prophecy the new system
was working really well and the
performance was great too we finally had
the beginnings of a solid animation
workflow in hazel i say the beginning
because well this really is only just
the beginning there are still so many
features that we need to add for example
as i mentioned blending between
animations is really really important we
also want inverse kinematics the
animation system also has to play nice
with the physics system these are the
kinds of things that the hazel team is
currently working on xerox has already
started working on the animation graph
system which will be really important
for deciding what states to blend
between and how and peter
peter's just having fun with ragdolls